[موسيقى]
هل تهربت من حالتي نراجع
يمكنني ان اقول ذلك لانني كنت في حاله عدم
التقبل لابني وهذا يعد هروبا من الواقع
ولو بطريقه غير مباشره ربما حاله النكران
في اللاوعي هي نتيجه رفض التقبل والتاقلم
لانك لا تعرف كيف تتصرف وتصاب بحاله ظهر
طبعا ارتيميا ساعدتني للخروج من هذه
الحاله واعدتني الى الواقع قالت لي ان
حاله ابننا لن تختفي فجاه ولن يشفى بحبه
دواء وينتهي الامر بعدما رايتما تفعله هي
الهمتني لاكون جزءا من هذه المهمه مع نياج
وبدات اساعد حينما اكون قادرا على ذلك
فبدات تحول من عدم القيام باي شيء الى
محاوله المساعده
[موسيقى]
ارى انني ابو لطفل لا يعاني من التوحد
وهذا ما يشعرني براحه نفسيه عارمه وانما
اقدمه لنيراج ليس لانه طفل توحد وانما
لانه طفل عادي هذا حقه ولذلك توقفت عن جلد
الذات لانه طفل توحد وهذه شهاده للتطور
الذي احرزه نيران